i am nick gillespie of reason do you
love reason the print magazine reasontv
the website reason com yeah I think so
and are you tired of politicians telling
you what to do it's BS frankly well
you're in luck because today is the
kickoff of our annual weba thought wow
we're looking to raise a hundred
thousand dollars in tax deductible
contributions over the next week to help
us fight for free minds and free markets
we need reinforcements up here reason
just celebrated its 45th anniversary and
with your donation we can keep dishing
up award-winning libertarian journalism
and commentary for years to come but we
do need your help if you give a hundred
bucks you'll get a print or digital
subscription to Reason magazine and a
classic black reason t-shirt for a
thousand bucks you'll get a private
lunch in DC with a reason editor but
regardless of the amount you'll get our
undying gratitude and a tax write-off
for whatever you can afford to send our
way all contributions will help us beat
back ever encroaching statism in
Washington and elsewhere you see this as
a problem from every one of reason
thanks for reading forgiving and for
listening last 30 seconds all I've heard
is blah blah blah